welcome back here watching Marvel live
here at San Diego comic-con 2019 you
know what I did I'm just excited about
Marvel Studios but you know speaking of
Marvel Studios now we've got some
amazing guest visual development team
please introduce yourselves and give us
your titles y'all working on a bunch of
really cool stuff right yeah nice to be
here my name is Andy Park and I'm the
director of visual development at Marvel
Studios no big deal my name is Jana
Chema and I just got hired three months
ago so yeah I'm super happy to be here
and yeah illustrator I do concept ads
yeah very cool my name is Jackson Z and
I'm a senior visual development artist
at Marvel Studios it's Jackson you've
been on the team since like Marvel
Studios Avengers the first film yeah
since 2011 2011 okay a little bit time
on you who may not know exactly what you
do like Bri because you're such a big
part of the Marvel Studios team like
explain what do you mean by viz death
like what is that yeah so it's very much
like the the formation Nick Fury brought
you know the Avengers together to fight
you know super super beings Kevin Feige
you know decided like we're gonna have
all these connected films so back in
2010 he commissioned Ryan miner Dane was
the head of visual development and
Charlie went who was back then co-head
to form a team of artists knowing that
we're gonna have all these films those
two were instrumental in the early films
Iron Man Thor Captain America and so
starting with Avengers knowing how big
that films gonna be they wanted to form
a group of in-house members and we've
been there ever since working on all the
films and it's been incredible we never
could have expected 10 years later that
we would expend the you know experience
endgame and it's insane yeah we have
these big beautiful art of
film you know hard covers that come out
with every film and so you guys all I
imagine have pieces that go in there and
yeah like the tapestry of that what is
it like collaborating because Jackson
and and Jana we were talking a little
bit earlier of like so how do you guys
work on stuff and who acts was saying
that yeah at the beginning was like
we're we're on one movie and then you
guys run two movies at the time and now
y'all are on multiple movies you're on
streaming shows what does that like for
you guys on a day-to-day it's all it's a
lot of work but it's all really fun work
and like you're saying we have so many
projects now we need to add more members
in our team and we're so lucky to have
Donna's talent to come help us out
incredibly fortunate to be there and
it's just a blast every day working on
very different shows the subject wise
they are very different a fantasy sci-fi
more real-world stuff it's been a blast
yeah I can second that I was working in
video games for ten years before and I
think I couldn't be happier to be here
it's very it can be very creative and
you have a lot of freedom to and
everybody in the team is super nice so
it's amazing so far yeah I think we
actually have a piece of yours here and
right yeah look at that right this is a
keyframe I did maybe last or earlier
this year depicting Black Widow fighting
taskmaster so this is kind of the first
to reveal wellguess Hall H revealed him
but this is the yeah really amazing yeah
it's a fun movie you know I've been
designing the Tosh's look ever since the
Avengers so you know it's very close to
my heart and to be able to work you know
Scarlett Johansson seeing her whole
journey throughout these films and
seeing her die in the last film is very
sad and
I know I know so yeah this special this
special and this movie's gonna be
special I think you bring up a really
good point that you have been working to
design black widow for for a significant
amount of time where does the process
start when you're really looking at
these characters their evolution and how
they move because you'll it's such a
beautiful thing to see them evolve
through the movies and also now
expanding out into a bigger world yeah I
think that's part of the fun because
we're working on these design of these
characters helping to tell the story
through their visuals but every single
film that they appear in is done by
different directors so initially it was
actually Jon Favreau right Iron Man 2
then you have Joss Whedon and then you
have the Russo brothers and now Cate
Cate shortland
under solo film so you know each of
these directors have a different vision
of course they have Scott Johansson as
the connected piece throughout the whole
though all those iterations but it's all
telling a piece of her story and I think
that's part of the fun in our job as
visual storytellers to kind of help
evolve that look and that to help tell
that story of each of these characters
Jana is the new kid on the block you
know just a couple months on the team
what was that first day like you come
into Marvel Studios you've had like 10
years experience to a video game stuff
but now you're in this connected
universe so all these you know these
things just like thrown right in okay I
would need you to do this this what was
it like it's the first time I have a
full-time employee job after such a long
time as freelance but they made it so
easy for me you know like everybody's
been so supportive and you know telling
me you got this and yeah I feel like any
didn't hold back in the stuff it gave me
too you know
if we went away some pretty complicated
stuff I'm totally going out of my
comfort zone but it's great that's how
you learn so I'm super happy yeah she's
doing amazing thank you for getting the
Black Widow film amazing Kate shoreland
loves her she calls her by name who
loses Jana yeah yeah it's very exciting
some really cool stuff I there's a lot
of movies that were talked about last
night I can't wait I'm sure you guys are
also moving even further ahead you're
you're like going ahead and doing stuff
Conchi we're running out of time but
thank you guys